there's a lot of questions I want to ask
you
about the nature of resistance and what
is the proper way to resist what is the
Practical pragmatic effective ways of
resisting so one example that is often
brought up is the difference between MLK
and malm X One emphasized nonviolent
resistance the other
emphasized any means necessary
resistance um which do side
with in general and in this
particular case of what has happened
over the past 100 plus days so in
general that framing relies on a
sanitization of Dr Martin Luther King Jr
and a vilification of Malcolm X that a
lot of people do put forth and present
as two Polar Opposites and how they
approached um the plight of black people
in America and and resisting uh racism
here in America uh when I taught a
course at at Southern Methodist
University on MLK in Malcolm X and Islam
and the Civil Rights Movement what I'd
often do is I'd give my
students a set of quotes and I would say
assign this to Malcolm or Martin and
they'd always get it wrong right so you
can find uh you know quotes from MLK and
breaking the silence and especially when
he took a stand against the Vietnam War
uh that sounds so radical you know when
you compare them to the the image of MLK
and Malcolm is of course turned into
this militant angry Muslim uh who just
wanted violence and was seeking uh chaos
here in the United States so let's be
clear about something here that
malol never himself was part of any
violence Malcolm never did anything
violent Malcolm found it hypocritical to
commit the oppressed people to
nonviolence while not re restraining the
oppressor from its
violence and I agree with Malcolm it is
absolutely hypocritical to focus your
attention and your energy on the
oppressed people and committing them to
nonviolence while not directing your
attention to the oppressor when you have
such a symmetry when you have a clear
aggressor and aggressed upon you have a
clear Colonial entity and a clear
colonized people you focus your energy
on restraining the colonial power you
focus your energy on restraining the
oppressor not the oppressed and so that
was Malcolm's point and it's clear in
his messaging uh throughout his
religious growth because of course
Malcolm did evolve as a person but
Malcolm found it deeply hypocritical to
commit the oppressed to nonviolence
Malcolm also had a
deep understanding of the way that
brutality here State violence in the
United States was connected to it State
violence abroad and American imperialism
as a whole Malcolm was the first to
speak on Vietnam the first major
African-American leader to speak on
Vietnam Martin followed Malcolm also
went to Gaza in
1964 went to Khan yunas which is now
under heavy bombardment and Malcolm Penn
an essay on Zionism and connected
Zionism to American imperialism and the
broader implications of America's
foreign policy
so Martin and
Malcolm if you look at them in the
capacity of what's happening right
now where I would say you can find
something that is deeply profound James
con wrote a book uh called Malcolm and
Martin Dreams and
Nightmares and he wrote something
profound to the effect that Martin tried
to liberate white people from their own
racism whereas Malcolm tried to liberate
black people from the effects of that
RAC racism on them and so they both
played a deeply important role
self-determination is crucial to
maintain the fuel of a movement and I
think one of the things that probably
deeply frustrates those that have sought
the Eraser of Palestine is that
Palestinian Consciousness has only
continued to grow after 75 years
Palestinians in diaspora and
Palestinians within occupied territory
all areep deeply rooted in their
Palestinian identity and existence and
they're not going away so I think that
that's where the the function is
important of this whereas those that are
complicit in the oppression need to be
liberated from their own oppression you
know and liberated from what they're
participating in most Americans that I
talk
to that have absolutely no idea about
what's going on when they come to hear
just a few stories of the plight of the
Palestinian people and the types of
brutality that we have
encountered wake up to this and say oh
my God this is what my tax dollars go to
this is what I'm a part of right so we
have to liberate people across the board
uh from being oppressors or from being
oppressed